[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINA WEISBERGER:
I'm Dina Weisberger.
PETER DOLCHIN: And
I'm Peter Dolchin.
We're both from the Global
Partnerships group on the Telco
and Video Distributors team.
DINA WEISBERGER: We'd
like to thank you
for taking the time out
of your busy schedules
to join us today.
Our talk is about
destigmatizing suicide.
And as someone recently
affected by it,
I learned, while it might be
a hard subject to navigate,
it is also crucial we bring this
topic from out of the shadows
and into the light.
The goal today and for future
Talks at Google on suicide
is to raise awareness
surrounding mental illness
and help create a space
for those affected
by it to feel supported.
So thank you for showing up
and demonstrating your support.
We and Nicole are on
a mission to change
the public perception of
suicide by eliminating
the silence around it.
We believe one of
the best ways to do
this is to connect a real
beloved person to a deeply
stigmatized word, suicide,
through stories and images.
Before Nicole talks about
losing her daughter, Dominique,
to suicide, she'll
share a brief montage.
While this may be an emotionally
evocative experience for many
of you, we hope that it
empowers those of you who
are suffering to reach out
for help, and for those
who know a loved one who is
struggling to approach them.
With that said, we wanted to
highlight the mental health
resources available
at Google and beyond.
Because the topic of suicide
is not one to be taken lightly,
we want to encourage anyone with
suicidal thoughts who are just
looking for someone to talk
to to please reach out to one
of the resources listed here--
the National Suicide Prevention
Hotline, the Crisis Text Line,
and the American Foundation
for Suicide Prevention which
you can just find support.
There are biological and
psychological treatments
that can help you address
underlying mental health
issues leading to suicide,
and we want everyone
to know there is a path forward.
Thank you.
PETER DOLCHIN: Thanks, Dina.
So onto our speaker for today.
We are fortunate and
I'm personally honored
to have Nicole
Browning with us today.
Nicole lost her beautiful and
talented daughter, Dominique,
to suicide in 2007,
and has made it
her mission to destigmatize
suicide and mental illness.
I've known Nicole
since 2005 when
I joined Viacom, which was
MTV Networks at the time.
Nicole led a team
of over 100 people
and was our fearless leader.
In the span of my
career, I've come
across a few truly genuine
and inspirational leaders,
and Nicole is
absolutely one of them.
She's a very special
woman and I'm
so grateful that she agreed
to speak to us today.
Nicole was a 21-year veteran
at Viacom, earning her way
to President of
Content Distribution
and Partner Marketing in 2000.
While there, she
increased revenue 10 times
to over $2 billion annually,
establishing her division
as the company's second
largest revenue producer
and building a portfolio
of over 20 valuable TV
networks including Nickelodeon,
MTV, Comedy Central, and VH1.
Prior to joining Viacom, Nicole
held various management, sales,
and marketing positions at
Rainbow Media, the Weather
Channel, Union
Carbide, and Xerox.
In 2007, after
leaving Viacom Nicole
founded her consulting firm,
Browning Media Consulting,
which includes such clients
as the BBC and Intel.
Following her daughter
Dominique's passing,
Nicole also founded Dominique's
Fund for Suicide Prevention,
a nonprofit in honor of
her late daughter aimed
at destigmatizing mental
illness and suicide,
and heightening awareness
of the magnitude
of suicide as a
global health crisis.
Nicole, thank you for joining
us to share your story.
Nicole Browning.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - THE FRAY, "HOW TO SAVE
A LIFE"]
NICOLE BROWNING: That beautiful,
happy-looking young woman
could have been anyone's friend,
cousin, sister, grandchild,
colleague, roommate.
A laughing, well-loved,
accomplished college student,
she was my daughter, Dominique.
I always have to give
myself a pat when I make it
through that screen, that
little video presentation
without bawling my eyes out.
Dominique participated in
much that life offered her.
She had wonderful friends
and adoring family.
She was the kind of
girl that all the girls
would go to to talk
about their problems
because she was so
sensitive and empathetic.
She was highly creative.
She wrote moving poetry.
She loved to travel.
She adored her dogs.
And she loved summers
in Rhode Island,
jumping off the bluff at
the beach into the water
with her cousins
and her siblings.
It was a favorite
pastime of hers actually,
and you know, playing olly olly
oxen free well into the night.
She sang like an angel.
Her voice was
incredible and moving.
And she was in many high school
musicals and college clubs
and bands and singing groups.
She was a busy, productive,
and highly successful student,
a college sophomore.
But another activity also
consumed my daughter's time,
and that was fighting a
terrible insidious disease,
a potentially fatal
disease, a disease that
attacked one of her
central organs, her brain.
It wasn't a disease that was
visible to all, or even visible
at all at times,
nor was it a disease
whose symptoms were constantly
overwhelming or always present.
Though it was a
disease that was always
there in the shadow
of her being.
My daughter's disease
was mental illness.
She suffered from an eating
disorder and bipolar disorder.
Her depression
especially was fierce.
11 years ago, at age 19,
Dominique died by suicide.
In the aftermath of
her suicide, I've
had to come to terms not
only with my profound
and terrible grief, but also
with all the judgments that
accompany a death by suicide.
So let's be honest.
Here are the kinds of things
that people think and sometimes
even say when they
hear about a suicide,
and I'm sure you could
all add to the list.
How could they do
that to their family?
Must have been another one
of those drug and alcohol
problems.
That kid was crazy anyway.
The whole family's nuts.
There must have been something
wrong with their upbringing.
Where was the family?
Weren't they paying attention?
How could those parents
let that happen?
How could she have done that
when there are so many others
fighting desperately
for their lives?
Or as in the recent
celebrity suicides,
how could they do that?
They had everything
going for them--
fame, money, family, like really
anything they ever wanted.
How could they do that
to their children?
What an incredibly
selfish act, or that's
such a cowardly way out.
Or, and I've been
told, there isn't much
that anyone can
do to help someone
who wants to kill
themselves, which
is just heartbreaking
resignation
by those convinced
that suicide is often
the unavoidable result
of severe depression
and that there is nothing
that we can do to change this.
Suicide feels to
those left behind
like some kind of
huge accusation,
an accusation made only worse
by the ignorance surrounding it.
In fact, many people
are so anxious to avoid
the stigma that surrounds death
by suicide that they will only
admit that a loved one was
lost in a car accident,
to an accidental overdose, to
heart failure, and so forth.
The humiliation is only
intensified by these kinds
of things that people say.
Now, imagine you are the
person actually suffering
with a mental disorder and
are having suicidal feelings.
Imagine the shame and
sense of burden to others.
That is a difficult
thing to overcome.
So difficult, in fact, that it's
often hard for those suffering
to ask for help.
They live instead in
silent pain and despair.
And in some cases, that can feel
so isolating that the darkness
turns inwards, a darkness
that makes the possibility
of leading a normal life
seem like an impossibility,
particularly and sadly
acute among our youth
who have to handle all
of this unnecessary shame
with far less life
experience, basically
far less time to understand
that what they feel
doesn't have to always
be that way, that leading
a productive fulfilling life
is, in fact, a real possibility.
We have, as a
society, a real lack
of awareness and understanding
of mental illness.
Mental illness is a
disease that knows
no socioeconomic boundaries and
touches the lives of literally
tens of millions.
This is a disease that
strikes our young as well
as our adults.
This is a disease that can be
so debilitating as to profoundly
affect productivity.
This is a disease
so misunderstood,
that's often viewed as
something someone can, you know,
snap out of it.
Self-induced, that
they could snap out
of it if they had a choice,
if they chose to do that.
Most horrifying is
that this is also
a disease that threatens
lives and claims many.
Yet shockingly, there
is a significant lack
of resources and research on
the potentially fatal outcome
of mental illness,
which is suicide.
This is a global health
crisis and yet so many
ignore it as such.
So you have to ask
yourself, well, why is that?
I believe that the prevention
of suicide and all the research
and the work needed is
greatly hindered by the shame
and fear so many feel about
mental illness and suicide.
Dialogue about this subject
should not be taboo.
A friend of mine shared
a tragically sad story
about a young 13-year-old
that was starting to behave
completely out of character.
Her family thought
she was having
some sort of psychotic break.
And as the child that this
family knew slipped away,
the doctors finally realized
that she had a rare form
of spinal meningitis.
Her brain was deeply
affected by the disease.
It was a tragic situation.
Nobody asked how she could
do that to her family.
She wasn't in control.
The victims of mental
illness should no more
be judged than the victims
of cancer, diabetes,
or any other life
threatening disease.
Nobody chooses to be stricken
by any of these illnesses,
and nobody is in
control, and nobody
blames them or their families.
Nor is one in control
when they kill themselves,
though that's very, very hard
for us to grasp because suicide
is self-inflicted, and
it seemingly requires
enormous control
because it's completely
contrary to every human
basic instinct of survival.
But when the brain
is diseased, it often
lacks the rational filters
that influence choice.
It's incomprehensible for those
who have never experienced
depression or other
mental illness
to fathom that one's brain could
ever misfire to such a point.
When individuals like my
daughter are depressed
and they make choices
that are self-destructive,
they are evaluating
their options
based on thinking that is
distorted due to the disease.
The pain of depression is
so completely unimaginable
to those who have
never suffered it
that it's hard not to think that
one can't pull themselves up
by their bootstraps
and deal with it,
or simply put a smile on your
face and then you'll be happy,
which I have to
confess is something
that I might have
said to my daughter
early on in her illness.
Sadness is not the same
thing as depression,
and understanding is even
more complicated by the fact
that it's an illness
that doesn't necessarily
take on physical
visible characteristics.
There is no obvious
broken bone, for example,
or another sign that
someone can point to.
The raw and gnawing pain
that leads one to suicide
is so alien to most of
our daily experiences.
And throughout the years, I
know you have all probably
read things and
listened to music
and seen art by so many of
these creative geniuses.
They tried to attempt--
you know, they tried to depict
the effects of depression
in their work.
Artists like Ernest
Hemingway, Virginia Woolf.
This might be really
completely dating me here,
but Edgar Allan Poe.
Actually these were books.
Sylvia Plath, Diane Arbus,
Vincent van Gogh, Bach,
Schumann, Kurt Cobain, and
recently David Foster Wallace.
The list just goes on and on.
Even the creatives
who personally
suffered the disease
were unable to provide
a clear and compelling
description that enabled
those unscathed by depression
to fully comprehend it,
though many have tried.
And I'm going to read
you some of the things
that I thought
were very powerful.
Sylvia Plath wrote this five
years prior to her suicide.
Quote, "I have been and
am battling depression.
I am now flooded with
despair, almost hysteria,
as if I were smothering.
As if a great muscular owl
were sitting on my chest,
its talons clenching and
constricting my heart."
Sounds pretty
painful, doesn't it?
Unquote.
Well, unquote before
it sounds painful.
Edgar Allan Poe
wrote this shortly
after his suicide attempt.
Quote, "I went to bed and wept
through a long, long hideous
night of despair.
When the day broke, I
arose and endeavored
to quiet my mind by a rapid
walk in the cold, keen air,
but all would not do.
The demons tormented me still.
I cannot live until I subdue
this fearful agitation,
which if continued would either
destroy my life or drive me
hopelessly mad," unquote.
And for me, nothing
helped me understand
what my daughter suffered
more than William Styron
when he wrote his book
"Darkness Visible--
A Memoir of Madness," and
this was the first book
that I read about the subject
after my daughter died.
Quote, "For in virtually
any other serious sickness,
a patient who felt
similar devastation would
be lying flat in bed,
possibly sedated,
and hooked up to tubes and
wires of life support systems.
But at the very least,
in a posture of repose
and in an isolating setting.
His invalidism
would be necessary,
unquestioned, and
honorably attained.
However, the sufferer of
depression has no such option,
and therefore finds himself
like a walking casualty of war,
thrust into the most intolerable
social and family situations.
There, he must, despite the
anguish devouring his brain,
present a face
approximating the one that
is associated with ordinary
events and companionship.
He must try to utter small talk
and be responsive to questions
and knowingly nod and frown
and God help him, even smile,"
unquote.
Thank goodness the mental health
profession and our medications
and all the things that
are available today
have really come a long way
since these writers wrote.
I believe we can all help,
and you are doing quite a bit
here at Google today by
simply opening yourselves up
to the conversation and
seeking to understand
something that may be so
completely unfathomable to you.
I believe, as I know
my daughter would have,
that silence only makes
the hopelessness of those
who suffer that much worse.
The CDC found that over half
the people who died in 2016
had no known mental
health condition.
One can only surmise
that for some
of these people, particularly
those that are successful
or that meet some objective
criteria of success,
that the stigma surrounding
their feeling of depression
or isolation are
likely even worse.
Depression is a disease
of hopelessness, despair,
and self-loathing.
We live in a culture
where successful people,
like probably every single
one of you in this room today,
and particularly
men can't easily
talk about their inner turmoil.
And why should they when
they are potentially
met with judgment?
Or what do they have
to complain about?
They have it all.
They've achieved success.
And if one has
made it to Google,
for example, where there is
boundless success everywhere,
it might even be harder.
And they've succeeded in
spite of their inner turmoil,
so like Styron
explained, you continue
with the many normal
aspects of your life.
You get up.
You go to work.
You go to dinner.
You read bedtime stories
to your children.
You kiss your wife, your spouse.
You grab a beer with
your pals, all the
while suffering and
battling your demons
and chiding yourself for not
being able to better resolve
it, amplifying that feeling of
hopelessness and self-loathing.
It becomes a vicious cycle.
Add to that relationship,
legal and financial woes,
physical health
issues, all of which
can become, according to
the CDC, triggering events,
and then there is a
recipe for more despair.
Ultimately, suicide is
certainly a mental health issue,
but it is also a
community issue.
Certainly many people
with mental health issues
never take their own lives,
and there are countless people
who have managed to survive
unimaginable horrific trauma
without being suicidal.
And then there are many on
the outside to seem to have it
all, and yet they're suicidal.
Imagine how shameful that might
feel to that person struggling.
According to many familiar
with the statistics
surrounding suicide,
the existing data
may be underrepresenting the
true extent of mental illness
in the US, but it
also speaks to why
eradicating the stigma around
mental health and suicide
is so necessary for
suicide prevention.
We need, as a community, to help
lift the isolation that further
intensifies the dysfunctional
thinking of someone considering
suicide.
Experts agree that teaching
people how to process loss
and how to cope with
difficult emotions
is an essential aspect
of suicide prevention,
so it's fantastic
that Google has
all of these resources
available to you.
My daughter,
unfortunately, is not alone
in succumbing to the potent
nature of depression.
How many of you here
today have in some way,
indirectly or
directly, been touched
by suicide in your lives?
And that's pretty typical.
It's almost consistently 100%.
I mentioned to Dina this
morning that after my daughter's
funeral, we made a
very specific decision
to be open about the
nature of her death
because we thought that
was something that she
would have really wanted.
And she was very
open in her community
about her eating disorder,
so we wanted to honor that.
I had no idea until after the
service when people came up
to me, one young man in
particular, and said,
I have to thank you.
I am so grateful
because 10 years ago,
my brother committed suicide
and nobody in our family
has been allowed
to talk about it.
And today, you have just
opened the door for me
to actually process my grief.
And that's when I
realized how so, so
suppressed the conversation
around this topic is.
Let me give you some idea of
the dimension of the problem
and the appalling lack of
funding for the prevention
despite the magnitude
of this issue.
So in 2016, which is the latest
data available, in the US
alone, the number of
deaths due to breast cancer
was about 40,000.
AIDS, 7,000.
Suicide, 45,000, more than
twice the number of homicides.
I'll say that again.
40,000, breast cancer.
7,000, AIDS.
45,000, suicide.
Add to this that for
every successful suicide,
there are about 25 attempts.
The numbers are staggering and
they have been rising sadly,
very, very rapidly rising.
The National Institute of
Health spent approximately $700
million for breast cancer
research and close to $3
billion for HIV/AIDS, and
thank goodness for that.
Now contrast that spent for
suicide, a mere $68 million
despite the fact that there
are more deaths than by breast
cancer and over six times
the death rate of HIV/AIDS.
And these are only a few
of the many examples.
Today, the number of suicides
among our youth is rising.
Our teenagers are especially
prone to impulsive acts.
Depression affects one out of
every five college students,
and that's the arc from
college to careers.
These are alarming
statistics, and like I said,
they're rising.
One night, several of
Dominique's college friends
did a very brave thing.
They called us.
They were worried.
Dominique had been talking
about ending her life.
They took her
seriously, something
that often doesn't happen.
Good friends never keep
a secret of someone
talking about suicide,
even if they are asked to.
They don't assume that
things will just work out.
And I later learned
from Dominique
that she was relieved
and grateful.
When her friends
reached out to her,
she felt a wall of
isolation lifted.
They gave her a gift,
and they gave one to us.
We had seven more
months with her.
Never underestimate the power
of simply being there for those
depressed, and guiding
them to seek help
or getting it for them.
Be brave, not indifferent.
Care enough to intervene.
And we can all make a difference
by starting the conversation,
which you all have,
offering support and lifting
someone's overwhelming
sense of being alone.
We can provide community
and a sense of belonging.
Be there for people.
Watch for signs,
signs like someone
expressing a desire to die or
feeling hopeless with no reason
to live, talking about
being a burden to others
or being trapped,
seeing someone's anxiety
just increase
exponentially, noticing
if someone is sleeping way
too much or way too little,
or if they're
withdrawing from others
or talking about a
future filled with pain.
Ask someone if you are
worried about if they
are considering suicide.
If the answer is yes,
be there with them.
Keep them safe and
connect them to support.
But most importantly, follow
up and make sure they get help.
Let them know they're not alone.
Suicide is not inevitable for
those feeling suicidal, which
is evidenced by the
effectiveness of the National
Suicide Prevention Hotline.
Someone being there
and helping someone
understand that
they are not alone
is often enough to save a life.
As you can imagine, all
of this is far easier
to accomplish when there
is an open dialogue
about mental illness
and depression.
Several years ago, I
spoke at the college
on this subject, actually
my daughter's college.
Some time after,
I received a note
from a young woman who
had been in the audience.
She wrote that as she sat
and listened to me speak,
much of what I shared about
my daughter's depression
resonated with her.
She realized that she too
was depressed and suicidal.
Just hearing me talk
so openly about it
was enough to give her the
courage to call her parents
and tell them how
she was feeling.
They withdrew her from
school, she sought help,
and she told me in this
note that I literally
saved her life, only
from a conversation,
only from letting her know
she wasn't alone, only
from letting her know
that she could get help,
it could be different.
I basically thought after
that I could hang up
because, you know, I
felt so good about having
that kind of an
impact, particularly
since I hadn't been successful
in saving my daughter's life.
My daughter tragically
took her life
while she was hospitalized.
They failed to pay
attention to the things
that she was saying
about taking her life,
chalking it up to her being
dramatic or attention seeking,
and even communicated
that to her.
The stigma associated
with her expression
of suicidal feelings, even among
some in the medical community,
could have only made Dominique
feel even more hopeless
and shamed.
We will never know what
she was feeling that night.
All we know is that later that
night, she abandoned all hope.
But we can't abandon hope.
Remember that most
people who are suicidal
desperately want to live but
are unable to find another way
to cope with their intense pain.
Intervening saves lives.
Suicide is a major global health
crisis, but it is preventable.
That's why I started Dominique's
Fund for Suicide Prevention,
and there are a number
of fabulous organizations
out there as well.
I believe, and I know
my daughter would have,
that silence around suicide
only worsens the hopelessness
that many feel.
That's why I must stand
in front of you today
and share what many might
think is a private and personal
family matter.
Talking about this, again,
should not be taboo.
We are only perpetuating the
misconceptions, the shame,
and the blame when
we remain silent.
Our mission is to change the
public perception of suicide
by eradicating the
stigma associated
with it and the
underlying mental illness,
and to empower those who
suffer from suicidal feelings
to seek help.
We are on our journey
towards recovery,
though none of us who loved my
daughter will ever be the same.
Suicide is said to
leave survivors,
the word used to refer to those
of us left in devastated limbo.
Imagine the battle of the
parents, spouses, family
of suicides, a battle where
there is never an ending, never
an answer, always and
only terrible questions.
I live with an unending
struggle to understand.
I replay every moment,
every decision,
everything I wish I had seen
with the benefit of hindsight.
That is a lot to survive.
Imagine the shame and loneliness
so many experience when they
lose loved ones to suicide.
Often, it's too
difficult for people
to even say to me that
they are sorry for my loss
when they hear the word suicide.
It's lonely.
Imagine the shame I feel.
All I ever wanted was
to be a good mother.
My love, which Dominique knew
and trusted and felt and wanted
and needed--
and I know that in my soul--
was not enough.
That is the worst
thing for a parent,
to realize that the deepest
love possible cannot save
a child's life.
I must now survive my battle
with the anguish and horror
of having lost a
child to suicide.
My deepest wish is that
Dominique could be here instead
to call herself a survivor.
I am also possessed by the hope
that others who are suicidal
can be helped past the shoals
of this devastating disease
and often very impulsive act.
I have come, though
it's taken me time,
but I have come to understand
that my daughter committed
suicide to end her
unbearable pain,
not to create pain for
the others she loved.
The day after
Dominique's death, I
began searching through every
piece of writing, of course,
trying to find answers,
desperate to know
what she was thinking.
Why?
And I found an essay,
and I'm not exaggerating,
an essay folded into
a tiny square that
just happened to be
in my bedside table,
and I had never seen it there.
My daughter was a
beautiful writer.
I felt like maybe it
was her way of trying
to shed some light
on it and give me
some kind of understanding.
It was a piece entitled
quote, "Dedicated to Those Who
Suffer in Silence," unquote.
It was mysterious as
to why it was there.
I don't know if she
actually wrote it
or if she copied it
from somewhere, though I
think it sounds like her voice.
But in any event, I know
it resonated with her.
I'd like to share a
part of it with you.
Quote, "It's not that
you don't want to live.
You'd love to be happy.
You'd kill to be
alive essentially.
It's not the dying
that's appealing.
I mean, you don't
really want to do it,
but you feel like you have to.
It's a matter-- well, a
matter of survival really,
which sounds like one
hell of an oxymoron I
guess to people who don't know.
See, all life really is is
pain every single damn day,
and it's not pain
you can look at.
If I break my leg and
it hurts, I can scream
and I can point
at my twisted leg,
and maybe a femur or
a tibia is poking out
to help emphasize my point.
But when your soul, your inner
being, your mind is hurt,
you can't scream
and point," unquote.
And then she continued.
"People say to look
towards the future.
It will be a better tomorrow.
What they don't
realize is that you
have looked towards
the future, and it
looks like absolute
and total agony,
which just makes you want to
steer clear of the next week.
People say it's selfish and
a cowardly and easy way out.
Sorry, but there is
no ease involved.
You don't want to die.
You want to be rid of
searing hot constant pain.
Nothing that you
can do to your body
will come close to the torture
that you live with every day."
I'm honored actually
to be here today.
You're working in a company
that has profoundly changed
all of our lives,
largely because this
is a culture that believes
that change is possible.
Otherwise, you
wouldn't even exist.
And Google is now a verb,
so you've definitely
changed things.
Eradicating the
stigma and helping
others out of isolated
pain is something each
and every one of us
can impact and change.
I think about the early
days not so long ago
of mental health treatment
when those with mental illness
were often restrained with
iron chains and shackles
around their wrists and ankles.
Today, the invisible
shackles binding
those with mental
illness are the cruelty
of misunderstanding, stigma,
and discrimination, which
our silence and passivity
only perpetuates.
We have made enormous
progress in fighting
this disease, but not enough to
even remotely claim a victory.
I hope that you will join
me and embrace our mission
and get involved.
I hope you pass on our
message and that you
find the courage to
talk openly about
mental illness and suicide like
I have done with all of you
today, so that it stands among
the other causes commanding
our attention and resources.
We have bracelets here
for men and women.
It's our dream that
we see this bracelet
on as many wrists as the
yellow and pink cancer rubber
bracelets so that this too is
understood as a disease that
needs our attention.
We want to tell the world
to pay attention to suicide.
We want these bracelets to honor
those who have died by suicide
and to remember them, and to
symbolize our hope and our work
to help prevent
further suicides.
We want to eradicate
the stigma and make
it OK to tackle
suicide like we've
tackled cancer, heart disease,
HIV/AIDS just to name a few.
The bracelet looks like this.
It's similar to the silver one
that Dominique loved to wear.
It's etched with a French braid,
a braid with four strands.
Dominique loved her
French grandmother
and loved the French language.
She often asked me to weave her
long hair into a French braid,
and her little
sister reminded me
that she could French braid
her own hair in as much time
as it took many of us to
put our hair in a ponytail.
So I guess that's
the kind of thing
that, if you're a little
sister, you're really
looking up to the big one for.
But I can still feel my
hands on Dominique's head
where they were from
the moment she was born,
cradling that teeny miraculous
new life, washing her hair,
combing it, braiding it,
and as she got older,
stroking it, wanting
to comfort her
with all the love
of a mother's touch.
I can't help but think that
the four strands representing
the four of us in her
immediate family, my husband
Steve and her twin siblings
[? Elody ?] and Hunter,
left behind to survive
this terrible loss.
Dominique once had a
very bright future.
She loved and she
knew she was loved.
She had hope for
all she could be.
All of that is gone.
I keep a lock of her hair
just as I keep in my heart
the memory of her smile which
I shared with you this morning.
Most of all, the
braid is a symbol
of the way in which
we need to entwine
our hearts, our efforts, our
learning, and our promise,
our help, and compassion
for those who need us,
for those who suffer in silence.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
NICOLE BROWNING: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very
much for coming today.
NICOLE BROWNING: Thank
you for being here.
AUDIENCE: My question is
related to death by suicide,
but also just
grieving in general.
What are some
things that you wish
people had done to
better support you
or that they did do
that was really well,
that you could sort of educate
us as potential supporters?
NICOLE BROWNING: What
a great question.
Well, first of all,
just understand
that it helps to give everyone
the benefit of good intention.
People want to support
people who have had loss.
They don't always know the right
thing to say, but they want to.
So you know, if you approach
it from that point of view.
So I think one of
the things that
has been a problem for me is
that even in my own family, not
my immediate family but
in my extended family,
they don't talk about
my daughter very much
and that really bothers me.
The first time I heard my
father-- bless his heart,
he's 94 now and
completely with it--
talk about how
many grandchildren
he had to somebody after
my daughter's death,
he had reduced the number
by one, and that killed me.
And you know, I
went to my father
and I told him how I felt
and he never did that again.
But I think the way
that you can be there
for people is not shy away.
I mean, honestly, I cannot
tell you how many people--
I was working at the
time and I got back
into the media
business, and people
who I hadn't seen since my
loss could not even say I'm
so sorry, because they
just couldn't say it,
because the idea of raising
suicide, thinking that it would
make me feel badly
even though, of course,
you already feel badly
so it doesn't matter.
So I think just
being open and direct
and asking people
what you can do.
How can I help you?
What can I do to help you
navigate your journey of grief?
And I don't believe personally
in the whole stages of grief.
I think everybody
does it differently
and everybody has
their own experience.
But I think it's important
to just be there,
to reach out, to check
in, and to share memories
of the person that's lost.
Because as someone who loves
someone who died by suicide,
you want their life
to be remembered.
You want to feel that
she had, in this case,
a big impact on people, even
if it was only 19 years.
And many of her college
roommates and her high school
friends, I'm still in touch
with and they share stories
about Dom and things I
haven't necessarily heard,
and it makes me really happy.
And I think the other thing
that is really important--
and someone did
this for me, just
to share a little bit of how
I navigated through this.
You know, of course
it goes in waves,
and there are moments,
holidays and other things
where you really feel their
absence even more acutely.
But I had a friend come
over and bring watercolors.
And Sandy's heard this story.
Peter, I don't know if you have.
But I'm like, I just
lost my daughter.
I'm not going to do any water--
like I don't paint, nothing.
And she said no,
just play with it.
And for that one moment, where
I wet water and put some paint
down, I was taken away.
And I realized then that
painting could be a good thing,
because part of the
grieving journey--
and this is also something I
think you can help people when
they're ready--
is to provide life
experiences and distraction
and you know, not
keep them sort of
out of living because you think
they may or may not be ready.
But you know, these
are all great ways too
of coping with loss and
any other tough thing.
So I've been painting a lot,
and in that moment when I'm
painting, I feel taken away.
And I have to say, there
have been at least two times
where I can honestly
tell you that I
think she moved my paintbrush.
So it's been an
interesting journey,
and I think that's
a great question
because people need
support and they need
to be able to talk about it.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Thank you so much.
You mentioned how to
show concern for somebody
that you're worried about and
the impact of just asking them
very specifically
if they're thinking
about hurting themselves.
During your grieving process and
your research on this subject,
have you learned
any tips that you
could share with
the room about ways
to potentially approach someone
or, you know, certain verbiage
even that might be helpful if
they're worried about somebody?
NICOLE BROWNING: I'll give you--
I want to just say I'm
not an expert on this.
There are fabulous
resources available,
even one of your counselors.
But what I do know is that
it is important to ask
if you have a question.
I don't know if there is
a special way to do that,
but I think one of
the most simple ways
is, I know you're
feeling really blue.
Are you thinking about
killing yourself?
Have you ever
thought about that?
And if the answer
is yes, you have
to pay attention because
it's not something
that people easily express.
And there is research, and maybe
you can speak to this more,
but there is research
that indicates that asking
the question is very important.
If they know, if
they actually have
an idea of how
they want to do it,
that's really a very big
signal that the severity
of the suicidality
is pretty significant
and needs to be addressed.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Dr.
[? Angela Young. ?]
I'm one of the AP
counselors on site.
So I just wanted to
add to that, Yes, it's
true that you do want to bring
the word suicide to the picture
because it's not something
that people often talk about.
So as soon as you
mention that, you also
give room for the
individual to share more.
But obviously, like you
know, if you are not sure
how to ask those questions,
it's always OK to say hey,
like you know, maybe
we can find a counselor
and we can talk
about this together.
There's a lot of resources
online where you can hook
someone up with therapists.
Like Psychology Today would
be a good place to start,
or if you know a
colleague, then [INAUDIBLE]
AP would be a great option.
But yeah, like you want to know
if they have thought about it
and if they had-- like you
know, if there's intent,
like how to do about it
or when is the last time?
And I would say for
a lay person who
is not in the field,
you can always ask,
what are some of the things
that are keeping you alive?
Like so that you know
if there is hope,
because a lot of times, they
might not be thinking about it.
Or they would be talking
about maybe family,
so then you know that they
are thinking about something
that is positive in their life.
But if they don't, if they
couldn't come up with a reason,
that's very alarming.
You want to bring them to
help as soon as possible.
NICOLE BROWNING: And the
National Suicide Prevention
Hotline site has many links
to, I believe it's called
#BeThe1To, that addresses
that very specifically,
what are the kinds of
things you can ask.
And it's a great resource.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]